you're gonna make me I by the plane  banting can you open the door uh maybe  open the door when I tell you  hey you know Raisa are you all right oh  never better it's a start hmm are you  riding me so hard I'm not riding you  baby I'm trying to make you understand  and you know how I run my house now  you're gonna have to go to school or  you're gonna have to go to work now I  don't even care if you are a janitor I  don't care what the hell yeah cuz I'm  the company i know i know that you don't  own the company Lonzo does you think  we're done here yeah I mean you can feel  like something to say to me you yeah but  he's a sales rep for Brightwell  pharmaceuticals mm-hmm and where did you  say you attended church well we  occasionally attend Riverdale community  mm-hmm so you would say you know Lord  yes i would say i know the Lord you  think the Lord is okay with this asking  price  you